あの三十四番目のニャーナダスニミッスッで終わりましたでしょうと思いますけど
パティパダーニャーナダスニミッスッ
一応またもう一回繰り返って
そこら辺からまたいきますか
いきます ヴィパッサナー瞑想
まあこれは普通の瞑想と違いますから
なかなかこの禅定のことを理解できないということはあるんです
ですから あの やってる人にとっては
なんか瞑想という感覚はしないです
で 瞑想しているんだという気持ち
感覚があるんだったら
これヴィパッサナーの世界でもないんですね
それはもう自己満足のために
まあ何かサマーディの方というかね
まあ喜びの方に行ってるだけのことです
で 智慧の世界っていうのは
この喜びの世界とかね
快楽の世界ということではなくて
とてもクールな世界なんです
それで瞑想している人にとっては瞑想という気持ちもなくて
なんかサマーディとかね
何か遠いしているんですが
自分の心は乱れているんではないかとかね
まあそういう感じでは瞑想してるんだけど
でもものすごい確実に心はもう一つの方向へ育てているんですね
それはもう観察する方法
何かもう認識して主観的に受け取る方法ではなくて
何も何も受け取らないで
認識として取らないで
ただ見ているだけの世界
だから自分の心は見ているだけの心に世界に成長しているんですね
そこにもサマーディが生まれているんです
落ち着いていて 何でも何でもいいんだから
ただ見ているだけの世界
だからそこを身につけてくる
サマーディというものは生まれてくるんです
生まれてくると このサマーディの結果として
このダサウパッキレーサという
このサマーディ ヴィパッサナーに迷惑な現象が十種類が生まれると前説明したんですね
それはこのサマーディの結果なんですが
サマーディ瞑想とまた違うんですね
サマーディ瞑想でわざと自分でサマーディ作って喜悦感
快楽感を感じているんですね
それで喜悦感 快楽感を感じたら
ああ これで良かったということで終わっちゃうんですね
そこで本人にとっては別にサマーディがやってる感じもないし
心はいつでも乱れっぱなしではないかという感じで
もう不満ばっかしで修行しているんですけど
突然体がすごく軽くなったりとか
いろいろ光見えたりとか
で いろいろものすごく鋭くシャープに知恵が出てきたりとか
すごいやる気が出てきましたとかね
で 何のことなく集中力出ているんではないかと
いろいろ能力がついてるような感じがするんですね
大体正しく修行する人にとっては
あれ なんだこれは？という
なんか疑問だけは生まれるんですね
これで良かったと思ったら
その人々はそれで終わるんですね
道は で そこは乗り越えなくちゃいけない
何か特別に普通の常識で理解できない何か現象が起きちゃったら
それを確認して もう何のことなく修行を続けなくちゃいけないんですね
囚われることなく そうすると全部消えちゃって
また元に戻るんですね
元の瞑想していた状態に戻ってしまうんですね
その元に戻ったことで
我々は道と道でないことを選んだというふうな言葉で言ってるんですね
マッガマッガニャーナダスニミッスッ
もうその世界をやめて
何もない観察だけの世界に入ったと
それから始めて しっかりとヴィパッサナーの方に行くんですね
それからまた二度とそういう同じサマーディの現象か光の現象か
特別な声の現象が そういうのはなくなっちゃうんです
それ状態終わったらさらに瞑想すると
もう落ち着いて観察能力できるんですね
特別な神秘体験もないんだから
あの もう一応 観察することはできるんですね
それで観察していくと
またいろいろ気持ちが変わっちゃうんですね
その気持ちはこの十種類のヴィパッサナーの智慧とと書いてるんですね
そのヴィパッサナー智慧のパーリの名前
こっちのテキストで書いてないんだけど
九つの智慧ですね ナバマハヴィパッサナーニャーナとパーリ語で言うんですね
ここでのまあ偉大なるヴィパッサナーの智慧と
一つはこの壊滅地と書いて
このバングニャーナとパーリ語で言うんですね
これはこの前の説明なんですけど
バングニャーナ バングというのは壊れるという意味なんですね
まあこういうのはもう大体必ずしも起きるんです
起きなかったらもう道が完成してないんです
ですから かっこつけても意味がないんです
私から説明してもらって
じゃあ分かったと それは何の意味もないんです
で どういうふうなことかというと
例えばもうすごくもう余裕がある心に上手に観察できる
普通なことをいろんなことを観察できる
それはきめ細かいことでも観察できる
いろんな思考が生まれてくるわ
痛みが生れてくるわ 音が来てくるわ
いろいろ それでも明確に観察できる
時々頑張っても全部 全部観察してみようではないかと
そうやって自分がこの観察することだけにチャレンジしていくんですね
確認することだけに で
チャレンジしていくと上手にできちゃったらすぐ気がつくんですね
やっぱり全部壊れていくんだと
この観察する現象っていうのは
で 壊れていかなかったならば
一つだけのを観察でいられるんです
例えば膨らみと観察したら
膨らみというのは壊れないならば膨らみだけで終わっちゃうんですね
永久的に でも膨らみといった途端
もう言う前にもまた他のものも観察しなくちゃいけないし
また体の震えが止まって
また逆の方向へ体を震え始まるでしょうに
それ感じるとそれももう確認しなくちゃいけない
ですから たくさん観察できるっていうのは
一つ一つの現象が消えていく
消えていくんだから 壊れて壊れていくんだから観察できるんであって
サマーディしているんだという気持ちはないんですよ
すごく落ち着きないように感じるんだよ
いっぱいものが物事が起きて
起きて 起きすぎて それを全部できるだけ観察してみようとするんだから
それでも諦める気持ちで
十分にこのやるべきことはないよないという気持ちも生まれてくるし
で どう 時になんとなく
まあ全部消えていくんだと
これも消えて あれも消えて
好きなものも消えて 好きなものも消えて
だからもう必死になって観察だけし続ける
必死になって観察し続けることできるということは
この物事 壊れていく 壊れていくことの智慧がもうとっくに生まれているということなんです
それを次に 脅威知ですか
ふい ふいというバヘニャーナが生まれるんですね
バヘニャーナというのは
この まあなんか全部壊れていくと思ったら
まあ当たり前で なんかすごく不安になっちゃうんですね
自分の体で観察するものも全部消えて消えていっちゃうし
二度と戻らないし 自分の心も同じく観察するともう消えていっちゃうんです
消えていった現象はまた戻らない
同じ現象の繰り返しもない
大体ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもやる方々はいつでも同じものの繰り返し欲しがっちゃいますでしょうし
それはものすごい煩悩なんですね
だからもういくら歯を噛んで頑張っても
全然精神的には成長しません
なぜならば瞑想をまるっきりしない真理に対して全く興味ない人々も同じことをやっているんです
だから人が俗世間に溺れていると
いつでも自分の財産ずっとあってほしいとかね
若さがずっとあってほしいとか
この豊かさがずっとあってほしいとか
死にたくはないんだと
永遠にこの世の中で楽しんで生きていきたいとかね
そうやって現象が変わってほしくないという気持ちが
俗世間に溺れている人々には明確にあるんです
だから瞑想にせよっても
何か同じ現象を繰り返してほしいという人の気持ちも同じなんです
だから成長しないんです
ただ苦労しているだけ
修行で それだったらもう何て言いますか
いっぱいお金貯まって
永久的に健康で元気で生きているんだというふうな世界に戻った方がやりやすいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
だからそういうことで苦しみが生まれてくるんでしょう
例えば 自分の子供が永久的に自分のところにいてくれるんだと思ったら
ものすごい苦しみしか生まれませんね
結局は親子関係もなくなって壊れてしまっちゃうんですね
捕まろうとすると だからこの俗世間ではそういう生き方なんですね
続けてほしいと この状態維持してほしいという
ですから 瞑想の世界では
そういう維持を ある状況をずっとあってほしいと思うことでは
もうヴィパッサナーの世界では意味がないんですね
智慧が成長してこない
性格は変わりません ただ苦いだけなんですね
それで 自分の心もなんだかんだもうずっと壊れて壊れていくんだと
何一つも止まって捕まるものもないし
いきなり恐怖感というものが出てくるんですね
不安感みたいなもんなんですね
だから俗世間では安定感があるでしょ
私に家がありますと だから安定しているんだと
結婚しましたと だから安定しているんだというふうに
この安定感があるんですね
あれは嘘ですけど みんなそういう安定感で生きているんですね
安心感というか 安定感というか
どちらでもいいんだけど
貯金はいっぱいありますよと
もう大丈夫やって 死ぬまで
そうやって安心感 安定感でみんなこの生きる苦しみを紛らわしちゃうんですね
それは普通の生き方なんです
その安定感 安心感壊れるんです
それをこちらでバヘニャーナと言うんです
だからこれは普通の人間にできる瞑想じゃないんです
こんなもう気が弱くて
頭が悪くて それは絶対できません
なぜならば人は何を探し求めているかというと
この安心感なんでしょうに
無常にやられて で 無常に気づかないんですね
その代わりに安心感探してるんですね
神様でもいいし お釈迦様でももう魂でももう何でもいいんです
カエルでも拝むでしょうに
合格してくれるんだったら
カエルでもキツネでも犬でも何でもいいんです
拝みた場合は 拝みたい場合は
これで大変あなたはもう
ま これは大変なもう守りと言ったならば
もうどんなガラクタでもお守りに使うでしょうに
別にそんなガラクタに別に何の影響もないんだけど
いろいろね 作って まあポケットに入れてあるんだけどね
まあそれウラニウムぐらいでも二
三 一グラムでもいいんだけど
ポケットに入れておけば大変な効き目がありますけどね
体中に でも・でも人間っていうのは安心感
安定感を探すんでしょうし
ですから そこ 弱いんだからなんですね
無常にやられっぱなしで
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想では
このかなり進んだ こういう一般の人のというレベルじゃない
このレベルはかなり進んでいるレベルですけど
この安定感 自分が今までずっと目指していた安定感が全部ことごとく壊れていっちゃうんです
全部このバンガニャーナで壊れていくんだということをわかってくると
ものすごく不安になってしまって
それはバヘニャーナ 不意の知恵というんですね
で それだけでも一般人とはもう変わっているはずでしょうに
一般の俗世間ではみんな安心感を探し求めているんです
そのために全ての活動をやっているんです
科学発展も経済的な活動も
精神 宗教的なことも 占いもインチキも全て
どうすれば安心しますか？ということですね
その安心感そのもの壊れてしまったら
安心は得られないんだというところだけでも
もうその人は一般の人々ともう随分違う
もう人間になっているはずなんですね
で それはまあバヘニャーナというんですね
で 次にあるのはこのカカンチ
オンリチ ダッスヨクチという瞑想ですね
カカンチっていうのはアディーナヴァニャーナ
一応パーリ語を書きます
[書き込む]アーディーナヴァーニャン
ニッビダーニャナ ムンチトゥ・カッメターニャナ
まあそんなに差がないんだけど
この心のどんな人間でも心が変わるこの順番でもあるんですね
そこで不意を感じる もう何も安心するとこはないんだと感じてしまったら
当然 2番目のアーディーナヴァー
こちらで書いてるのは可観という言葉なんですけど
可観ってどうでしょうか
わかりませんだけど この
アーディーナヴァーっていうのはパーリ語で大変よく使う言葉で
なかなか適切な言葉ないんですね
訳する場合は まあ俗的な言葉で言えば
このまあ長所短所の短所ということなんですね
アーディーナヴァーっていうのは
で 短所見えてくるんだと
もう悪いところばっかし見えるんだっていうことなんですね
全てのものは壊れて消えていく
そうするといいとこ何 1つもないでしょうに
だから当然ものすごくつまらないんだと
まあくだらないものやと
何一つにも何の意味もないんだと
だから自分が観察しているっていうことは
自分が生きてるっていうこと
普通に観察していくんだから
ただ普通に観察してることは自分そのものなんですね
この自分そのものって言ったっても
見る 聞く 味わう いろんなことでしょうね
それまとめて自分と言ってるんだから
そこで見るものにしたっても
瞬間瞬間に何のこともない
すごいことを見たわけでもないし
それによって何か自分が得たわけでも何もないんですね
ただ見た 喜んだ あるいはつまらなかった
それだけなの 喜んだっても喜びという感じ
感覚もすぐはじけてしまっちゃうし
何か見ても怖くなったら
その恐怖の感情もすぐ瞬時にもはじけていっちゃうし
で 結局一体全体何ですかと
音が耳に入って気持ち悪くなったっても
それまたすぐはじけていっちゃうし
すごい気持ちいい音だなと
別にそれも瞬間で消えてしまっちゃうし
だから 俗の俗世間の人と違って
あ この声が綺麗だ これは録音して持っていこうとかね
毎日この時間でここに待ってみようとかね
そうするとこの美しい声が毎日聞こえるんだとかね
そんな馬鹿げた話がなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならば安定したいという気持ちはあったんだけど
壊れちゃったんですね
それで見えるのはもう音にしても何やってもはじけていくだけで
もう何のこともないと
何も意味がないんだと
価値がないんだということを見えてくる
それはアーディーナヴァーニャン
可観智なんですね 短所見える智慧
だからって今 今の状況ではやっぱりものには短所あるんだったら長所もあるんじゃないか
そんなもう屁理屈はもう今は当てはまりません
最終的には短所しか何もないんです
即時で次元ではご飯だったらまあ適当に食べればいいと
ちょっと大量に食べれば悪いんだと
そういう風に長所短所両方見るんだけど
これ今の次元では全て壊れて消えてしまうということをわかったら
まあただ短所のみ 他の何もないんだとわかってきます
で 短所が出てきちゃったら
一般的にはまあ諦めるんですね
好みがなくなっちゃう
未練がなくなっちゃうんです
この未練が消える 自分に対して
この自分が生きてることの修行だから
だから見る 聞く 味わう
感じる そういうものに確認してほしいと
呼吸瞑想とかね 南無妙法蓮華経とかね
あるいはオームとか そんなものを瞑想するなというのは
厳密にっていうのはそういうわけなんです
サマーディ世界では そちらにはそれなりの意味がありますけど
智慧の世界ではそれはもう全く幻覚の世界で意味がないんだと
だから自分というものは実践しなくちゃいけない
だから見る 聞く 味わう
考えている 妄想している
雑念がある そういう普通なことを感じて
それが自分生きているということでしょう
それ以外何もないんだから
私が私がと言ってますけど
結局何ですかと もう体でいろいろなことを感じるわ
目でいろんなものを見ているわ
そういうものについていろいろ延々と妄想しているわ
それぐらいのことでしょうに
ですからそこは観察していくと
そういうものは全部はじいているんだと
やっぱりもう安心感を得られないんだと
もう怖いもんだとわかってきて
それで短所ばっかし見えてきて
つまらないんだと 価値観としてはもう意味だと
もう何のこともないという価値観的な智慧なんですね
それからニッビダーっていうのは価値観わかったら結論出さなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから結論出す前にもう未練が消えちゃうんですね
まあ短所しかないんだと
無意味だと もう諦めましょうということで未練が消える
これ心変わるんですよ
未練がなんとなく消えてしまうということでニッビダーニャーナというんですね
ニッビダーニャーナはこのテキストでは怨リチですか
怨リチというんですね
もう諦めたら未練が消えちゃったらもうもう醜い世界ですね
自分という世界は 醜いというよりは
もう無意味な世界なんですね
壊れて食われていくものだけで
何もなくて 何も頼りになるものはなくて
それで今まで自分自分というこの気持ちがね
なくなっちゃうんです
なくなって このこんなこの現象のこの流れ
限りなくこの現象の流れをから流れをね
それから離れたい 脱出したいという意欲が生まれてくるんですね
これには溺れて見ました
喜んだ 食べた 楽しかったとかね
そればっかしの人生はやめましょうと
もう意味がないと 世俗的な世界で全ての生命がやっているのはそれだけのことなのよ
食べた 楽しかった 見た
楽しかったと 食べた もう美味しくなかったと
今度は他のものを食べましょうとかね
それだけの人生で 全ての生命が永久的に輪廻の中で生きているんですね
他の何もやってないんです
だからこの現象の流れからもう離れましょう
関係ないことにしましょうという気持ちが生まれてきます
いわゆる じゃあ関係ないことにしましょうと
今までは随分関係 関係するものは煩悩のことなんですね
我々には関係あるんです
私の子供ですと言った途端
そこにすごい関係ある
私の国ですよと言った途端
すごいそこで関係が成り立っている
私ですよと言った途端
そこにものすごい強力な関係が成り立ってるんですね
私ですよと言ったら 私に対していろんなことをしなくちゃいけないんだから
責任で生まれてくるでしょうに
私の目ですよと言ったら
目に対して責任感生まれてくるんじゃないんですか？生まれます
だからそこをなくなっちゃうんです
もう関係ない どんなものにも
で 関係なくなっちゃうということは
このこちらは脱欲智と書くんですね
ムンチトゥっていうのは
まあ離れたいというカンメタ
意欲が生まれてくる やっぱり関係ない方がいい
まだ関係なくなったわけじゃないんだ
関係ない方がいいんだと
で 関係ない方がいいんだと思うのはいいんだけど
どうやって関係切る 断ち切るかということはね
まだまだないんですね
そこで次の智慧が出てくるんです
それでその修行する本人がもう
もうこの現象の流れとはやっぱり関係ない方がいいんだと
と思う 思うんじゃなくて
関係ない方がいいというふうに自分の心が変わるんですね
で 変わったところでやることそれでもないんだから
また続けて まあただの現象だから
まあ見ておこうということで
単なるこの観察だけ続けていっちゃうんですね
また 今ま・今まで説明した同じヴィパッサナーのやり方なんです
でもそれはちょっとレベル違うというか
今まで自分で修行したんだけど
今はもうそういう気持ちもない
修行したいという気持ちもない
したくないという気持ちもないし
もうなんかやらなくちゃいけないという責任感もないし
早く悟らなくちゃいけないというそれもないし
もう心がもう全ての希望がなくなっちゃったんです
失望になっちゃったんです
希望叶ったわけじゃなくて
一切の希望がなくなったら人はどうなるんですかね
何もやることなくなっちゃうんです
それぐらいの気持ちで
ただまあ 体のこと 心のことをただ観察・考察していくだけ
だから観察するすべて自分に
一般的にも自分に関わるものでしょう
カラスが餌に喧嘩しているんだと
それはカラスの世界だということじゃないんです
それ見てるのは自分だからね
だからカラスの欲があって
嫉妬して お互いに喧嘩
まあカラスは嫉妬しませんだけど
で お互いに例えば餌に喧嘩しているんだと
まあそれはカラスの例はあまり良くない
カラスは餌には喧嘩しないんですね
まあカラスは不思議な動物で
餌があったら喧嘩しません
分けるんです いっぱいあるんだったら他のカラスを呼ぶんでしょうしね
他の動物とは随分違うんですね
まあこのカラスの話は関係ない
まあ例えば犬は喧嘩するんですね
どうせ 犬は餌に喧嘩しているんだ
やっぱり犬だからね そいつらはね
餌にもうこうやって喧嘩しているんだと
いう他人ごとに観察するということじゃないんですよ
世の中で自分以外の何か現象あるわけじゃないんです
それは自分が目で見て自分がそう感じているんです
ですから たとえ犬の喧嘩観察していたって
ヴィパッサナーで観察しているんですね
犬の怒り 犬の嫉妬 犬の欲望
それで欲望があって 嫉妬があって
そこに苦しみが生まれてくると
と思っても それは客観的な犬のことではないんですよ
結局は 自分の経験なんです
自分にそういう智慧がないか・なかったらあれはわからないでしょうに
[咳]そういうことで
何を見ていたっても 本人はこのヴィパッサナーの立場からもう全部観察して
鋭く観察していく 鋭い観察能力出てきて
すぐそういうふうに見える
他の角度で尺度でもう見えません
これはもうかなりレベル高い知恵の世界なんですね
すごくスイートは鋭くなるんです
犬のケンカ ケンカ ケンカやめましょうとかね
という風な もうそういう気持ちじゃないんです
それはもう現象の世界を認めている人なんですね
喧嘩やめて犬同士を犬二匹を平和に仲良くしてあげましょうと
それは幻想もいいところなんですね
そんなものは存在しないんです
結局 全て無常だから 変化するんだから
餌が足らないんだから喧嘩しているんだと思って
それで餌いっぱいあげたんだからといって
怒りと嫉妬とそれによって生まれてくる煩悩の世界
苦しみの世界なくなるんですかね
なくならないでしょうに
それで犬という外にいる動物にそれを教えてあげることもできるんですかね
それもできないでしょうに
ですから そういう即席の人々の考えているように
何かについて意見とか
何かについて感想とか
これはこうであるべきですよ
ああであるべきですよという主観とか
何一つもない ただ観察しているだけ
犬の喧嘩を見ても そこは犬の喧嘩でもなく
自分でもなく 単なる欲があって
怒りがあって 嫉妬があって
そこに苦しみということが生まれて
それで欲望があったりして
希望があったりして そうやってもうその流れがね
またそれを瞬時に変えていく
ずっと喧嘩してたって
ちょっと餌あげただけでまた喧嘩やめちゃうでしょうし
そこでお腹いっぱい食べたところで喧嘩した二匹の犬がまたじゃれてお互いに遊んでるでしょうに
だから何一つにも実体がなく
瞬間瞬間に変化していくという
そういうふうな もうちょっとレベル高く観察し始まるんですね
その観察できる能力 いわゆるもののものを見える
瞬時に 言葉でもって確認しなくても
ピシンとも電気ショックみたいに見えるんです
見ただけで その間隙間ないんです
で 見えてます 見えてますとか
ああだこうだとかね そういう言葉でラベリングするということはものすごい遅いんです
まあ言葉でラベリングすると
物事はもの-もう変化して変わって
もう全くもう違うものが生まれてくるんです
ですから 鋭い何かシャープ
ものすごい鋭いシャープの観察能力は必要になっちゃう
それには言葉がない もう見たらもうそのそのままもうわかっていると
それぐらいの観察能力をそこでパティサンカのパティサンカーニャーナと呼ぶんですね
そうやって自分の内なるもの
外なるものという分け方もなくなります
内なるものであれ 外なるものであろうが
全て自分関係のものだからね
それはどちらでも観察する時は内なるもので観察する
外なるもので観察する
あるいはまあどちらでもなく
もう関係あるものだというふうに
第3番目の立場で観察する
どっちでもいいんだけど
それで観察していく いくとウペッカーニャーナというものが生まれてくるんです
このところで この一番大事なのは
このパティサンカーニャーナなんて一番大事ってわけじゃないんだけど
このパティサンカーニャーナっていうのは
もう言葉なくてもやらなくても
この瞬時に見えるという
この現象 その智慧なんですね
大体このこの次元では
この煩悩とか怒りとか欲とか
そんなものはもう別に気にしないんです
悟りとか輪廻とか そんなもうもうものすごいすごい哲学者なんです
そこでその人に見えるのは
現象が現れて消えていくだけのこと
それはたとえ怒りであろうか
瞋恚であろうか 智慧であろうか
精進であろうがね 善心所であろうか
不善心所であろうか もう何であろうが関係なく
ことごとくまあその状況
その条件によってすぐ生まれてすぐ弾けていく
すぐ生まれてすぐ弾けていく
だからラベリング 言葉でラベリングはもう無理なんですね
なんか自分でも自分が何やってるか分からないほど
もうなんかもう大きな鏡
鏡の玉に上下あっちこっちから全ていっぺんに映ってるでしょうに
それで鏡はこの丸型というか
この球型になっちゃったら結構全て映るんですよ
あのカーブありますからね
不思議なことに 入らないもの何もないんです
で そんなものになっちゃうんですね
だから我々の体から見れば
眼耳鼻舌身意を持つしかないんだから
そこに映るものに対して
まあどこからどうしたっても関係なく
その瞬時にもうやっぱり全部生まれて消えていくだけのことでね
弾けていることだけです
それはもうジリジリと映り始めるんですね
だからまあ膨らみ縮み見ているんだから
このまあ痺れなんか置いておきましょうとかね
じゃあ音なんか確認しないようにしましょうとか
そんなレベルじゃないんです
で それはもう論理的に
僕は論理的に心は一方の流れで流れているんだということで言ってるんだから
やっぱりこの速さもわかってきて
見る瞬間 それを見て 聞く瞬間
それを聞いて 考える瞬間
それを見て 全部もう観察できるというふうになってくる
そこですぐに今まであった一切の希望消えちゃって
喜びも消えちゃって 完璧な失望者になって
で 完全たる失望者に生まれてくる感情は何ですかね
ウペッカーなんです 怒りではないんです
怒り生まれるのは何か希望があってそれなくなったんだからなんです
もしかするとその希望が実現できたのではないかということで
怒りが生まれてくるんですね
そこで絶望するものは何もないんだと
安心するものは何もないんだと言ったから
腹が立つにも腹が立たないんで
誰に対して腹が立つんで切りがない